it's just great to be back i when i was
growing up my the idol of my life was
bette midler kathy najimi is happy the
sanderson sisters are together again for
hocus pocus 2. how time flies when
you're dead
[Laughter]
the actress is back in witchy action
with both bette midler and sarah jessica
parker for the sequel to the 1993
classic and when kathy caught up with
e.t about her latest film single all the
way she couldn't help but gush about her
on-screen big sister i used to break
into back stages of where she was
performing i had guards chasing after me
true story found her apartment in new
york left her a note got drug away from
there so to be standing next to her not
only in the same movie but playing her
sister blew my
mind
earlier this month disney plus gave fans
a first glimpse of the sanderson sisters
on set of hocus pocus 2. with this photo
featuring the ladies in their original
attire as mary winifred and sarah
sanderson
bett shared her excitement posting the
same pic on instagram with the caption
sis does tis time aren't you broad's a
little old to be trick-or-treating
we'll be younger in the morning we'll
have to wait till 2022 to watch hocus
pocus 2 but here's what to expect from
the sequel in the meantime it is just a
bunch of focus poses hocus pocus 2 is
picking up 29 years since someone lit
the black flame candle and when three
young women accidentally bring back the
sisters to modern day salem they must
then figure out how to stop the witches
from wreaking havoc on the world does
that sound familiar we must find the
book drew the potion and suck the lies
out of the children of salem before
sunrise while we wait for the arrival of
hocus pocus 2 you can catch kathy in her
new film single all the way your family
really wants you to have a relationship
yes i know that's very clear so my early
christmas present for you is a blind
date i love it he loves it you're going
you're going where you going he's going
on a blind date like from grindr oh my
god
while chatting with her and co-star
jennifer coolidge kathy shares about how
proud she is being a part of netflix's
first holiday rom-com featuring a gay
couple i love that it was a love story
between two men but it wasn't about them
being two men it was just a love story
and i love that and a comedy at the same
time they really accomplished a lot
you know we've seen we've seen movies
where there are gay leads but a lot of
times it's very sad and ends up horrible
and a family member is against it and
they get sent away somewhere and then
we've seen you know like this one was
about christmas about family and the
the lead just happened to be
a really handsome gay guy looking for
love kathy and jennifer also reveal all
the fun they had together on set like i
had a hard time keeping it together
kathy i really did like i don't know we
were
um
it was hard to get not laugh i don't
know like it was hard and i it was hard
when when jennifer arrived on set for
her first scene because we were there
for a couple of days before she was um
because she insists on only working one
day a week but when she finally showed
up i'm kidding you
the whole tone just changed and
the the the door to improv got to be
open and
you know she's a genius
[Music]
you